hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
cern kierkegaard's essay the present age
might appear on a first reading rather
pessimistic if not dismal about the
prospects
of having an authentic existence
for oneself but if we actually look at
it quite carefully we don't even have to
necessarily
read between the lines we just have to
read the right lines
in this and bring the passages together
we can see that
things are actually not that bad
in this era of leveling
the public dominating things getting
more and more abstract as it goes along
with the press
nullification of contradiction the loss
of passion and therefore of commitment
and genuine action all of those
are in fact true of the era and of the
culture
and of many individuals but they don't
have to be
the only option for any one
given person as kierkegaard shows
us and we're gonna talk about how he
views
the the current age the present age of
his time
as actually providing a sort of
clarified set of opportunities
for a person to live an authentic
existence
first of all we should talk about the
different options
that lie before any given person and and
one of the things
that is characteristic of
the culture that he's diagnosing is that
it it
sort of precludes some of these options
it's not gonna if it was
handing out a poll or a checklist it
wouldn't include some of these options
on it because they're not
options that the age can actually
understand well
so the first of these is just to become
a creature of one's
own age or culture and this is
this corresponds to what kierkegaard in
other places
calls the aesthetic in the aesthetic
sort of
existence the aesthetic way of life
where you just kind of flit from thing
to thing
and you know the current age because it
is one that nullifies contradiction
and because the public can believe one
thing one moment and then believe
another thing another moment
it facilitates this kind of rootlessness
never actually
settling down and committing to anything
being
semi-committed committed you could say
in principle
for a season and then committing to
something else just as well you know
you know you know many many people like
this and there are entire industries
that are like this fashion industry for
example
is is very much like this um there's a
danger of the culinary industry lapsing
into these these sorts of things
as well and so
one can just sort of like you know
essentially
be a consumer of the culture
or of commodities and that would be one
one option
and by doing so one
loses out on an authentic existence
but maybe you don't really even miss it
another possibility he talks about is
connecting oneself
with others finding something you know
bigger than you
and he calls this sociality or
association
he devotes a lot of discussion to how
people will
you know line up with each other
mathematically
so that a certain number of people put
together finally cross a certain
threshold
and become a person or an individual
which sounds you know paradoxical but
that that's how he explains it
so they'll write a petition or they'll
found a group or they'll they'll be some
sort of value
that is being put forth in some sort of
uh
contrary value or anti-value that's
being gone against
but the problem with this is that unless
you actually have an individual who can
take a stand
on his or her own which requires some
development on their part
putting a whole bunch of people together
so that they can take a stand
doesn't really amount to much and he
he's got a a very interesting discussion
of this actually several interesting
discussions i only want to
look at the first he says it's very
doubtful our age will be saved by the
idea of sociality or association
and he says that in our age the
principle of association which at best
can have validity with respect to
material
interest is not affirmative but negative
it is an evasion
a dissipation an illusion whose
dialectic
is as follows as it strengthens
individuals
it vitiates them it strengthens by
numbers
by sticking together but from the
ethical point of view
this is weakening and he tells us that
not
until the single individual has
established an ethical stance
despite the whole world not until then
can there be any question of genuinely
uniting
otherwise it gets to be a union of
people who separately are
weak a union is unbeautiful and depraved
as a child
marriage he says so you know two people
young people getting married together
and not really having developed
themselves to
to the degree that they they need to
well you take a bunch of
weak individuals and put them together
into a group to enact some common
purpose they still remain weak
and might be made even weaker as a
result
now those are things that sort of
cooperate with the times what if you
said
we're going to resist this process of
leveling
we're not going to take this we're going
to be
uh you know anti-modern or hyper modern
or we're going to be conservative in
this respect or we're going to stand for
true progress whatever it's going to be
right that's not really going to be a
workable option
either why because it actually plays
into the process of leveling itself even
though
one doesn't realize it even though one
might be trying to
stand against it and it's very
interesting to see
how various forms of conservativism
uh in in just in the last you know
century and a half
essentially either they held on to
things stubbornly and then were
washed over because they they had their
heads in the sand
uh and really couldn't react to
situations or they end up abandoning
conservativism entirely even though they
call themselves conservatives and
embracing all sorts of other things and
engaging in essentially nullification of
contradiction where they like totally
flip their sides
you know the nra becomes against gun
control when it was originally for gun
control you know
we come up with all sorts of examples of
of this sort of thing and so
these are essentially doomed and so if
you're going to hit your wagon to that
proverbial star
of a people of an idea
of something like that that's going to
resist leveling
it's not really going to work so
what's another possibility you notice
that that kierkegaard
talked about the possibility
of the single individual establishing an
ethical stance despite
the whole world that means that they
make a commitment
even knowing that they may not get
rewarded for it even knowing that they
may be misunderstood
in doing so and kierkegaard here is
going
to talk about the religious as well
now in in kierkegaard's works he will
typically bring up the ethical and the
religious as things that are
in some respect not necessarily
opposed to each other in the grand
scheme of things but certainly
seem to be in the religious being above
the ethical the ethical being something
that can be understood
something that can be explained
something that applies to you know the
whole there's there's various levels of
it and then the religious is this leap
that one takes into the absurd and into
obedience to god or love for god or
something along those lines here
he's not making that that such a strong
a distinction
but there is a important connection here
so if we look at the passage where he
first
brings up the unrecognizables i think we
get to see
where he's going he says in older in
older structures
the non-commissioned officers company
commanders generals
the hero that is the men of excellence
the men prominent and the various ranks
the leaders were recognizable
each one according to his authority
along with his little detachment
was artistically and organically ordered
within the whole himself supported and
supporting the whole
but now the men of excellence the
leaders
will be without authority because they
will have divinely understood the
diabolical principle of the leveling
process
like plainclothes policemen they will be
unrecognizable concealing their
respective distinctions and giving
support only
negatively while the infinite uniformity
of abstraction judges every individual
and examines him in his isolation and he
says this is the dialectical opposite to
that of judges and prophets
and just as they risk the danger of not
being respected for their
respective authorities so the
unrecognized run the risk of being
recognized being seduced into acquiring
status and importance as authorities
thus preventing the highest development
like secret agents they are
unrecognizable
not according to private instructions
from god but they are unrecognizable
because of their
apprehension of the universal inequality
before god because of their acceptance
of the responsibility for this at all
times
and so they have to resist the
temptation of people making them into
judges or
prophets or authorities and they have to
go on
doing what they're doing as the
unrecognized
as you know what uh in in other places
kierkegaard will call the night of
faith possibly also the night of
infinite resignation as well it looks
like
here the ethical and the religious kind
of uh
occupy some of the same space and so
that's one of the
options for the the single individual
that is the option that kierkegaard
himself is pursuing that's the option
that he's
suggesting to us although he's not
saying you must
thou shalt that would be silly it's up
to every one of us
authentically existentially to decide
for ourselves do we want to do these
things
or do we want to do this and this is a
this is a decision between
the present age and
what kicker guard is calling eternity
he also thinks that there's a great
opportunity for
the single individual in his time why
well because the leveling process
is not as all-powerful
as we we think that it is i mean it's
all powerful
with respect to the world and with
respect to
society and culture but
that doesn't mean that it actually
closes
off all possibilities for us it doesn't
mean
that there's nothing else possible and
he's got this
great discussion here about how it is
that one might here we go
one might not just resist and evade
leveling
but tap into something going beyond it
says in its immediate and beautiful form
the principle of individuality
prefigures the generation in the man of
excellence
the leader and has the subordinate
individual's group around the
representative
but in its eternal truth the principle
of
individuality uses the abstraction
and equality of the generation as
levelers
so it's using what what the current
world is doing
and thereby
religiously develops the cooperating
individual
into an essentially human being
by looking at the world by looking at
these processes and saying there's more
than this
i believe there's more than this i'm
taking the risk i'm taking
the leap that there's more than this
something more
can happen he says leveling is just as
powerful with respect to the temporary
as it is impotent with respect to the
eternal
what is eternal in us what is eternal in
our relation to
whatever is is greater than us in
in the you know a real sense uh
could be god could be something else for
kierkegaard obviously it is god but
there's there's discussions about what
else
it could be whatever is the eternal
that has that sort of value
the leveling process can't really touch
that
it can touch its worldly manifestations
it can keep you from being able to go to
worship
it can ban books or make them no longer
marketable so you can't get them
but it really can't touch the eternal
because leveling is a temporal process
it is a process of the age and so a
little bit later on in the passage that
i
quoted just a few minutes ago he tells
us that
the skepticism necessary
for the proper development of
individuality
takes place in our age because of
leveling because so many things have
been turned into
they're not actually the the wonderful
thing that we should idolize and throw
our affection
and our lives into we can be like well
yeah i mean
that's not as great as we thought so
this skepticism
uh he says is necessary in as much as
every individual either is lost or
disciplined by the abstraction finds
himself
religiously and this finding ourselves
religiously taking the
leap is the possibility
for us now these unrecognizables there's
one other thing to say about this
he tells us that the hopeless
abstraction of leveling
will be kept going without interruption
by
its servants lest it all end with the
return of an earlier structure
and these servants are in fact the
servants of the power of evil
for leveling is not of god and every
good man will have times when he could
weep over its hopelessness
but god permits it and wants to
cooperate with individuals that
is with each one individually and draw
the highest out of it so
kierkegaard is taking a traditional
christian idea
that god draws good out of evil and he's
not saying that you know i'm getting
this from
you know a revelation on high he's
saying this is how we can understand it
existentially
he says the unrecognizables recognize
the servants of
leveling but they don't use power or
authority against them
because then there would be a regression
and they would be authorities
only through a suffering act will the
unrecognizable one
dare contribute to leveling and by the
same suffering act
will pass judgment on the instrument
he doesn't dare to defeat leveling out
right he would be dismissed for that
because that would be acting with
authority
but in suffering he will defeat it and
thereby
experience in turn the law of his
existence
which is not to rule to guide to lead
but in suffering to serve to help
indirectly and the harry says those who
have not made the leap
probably won't recognize this those who
have made the leap
will have a vague idea that it was his
victory but they will not be certain
because certainty could come only
from him and so
what we've got here is a world in which
potentially tens of thousands even
millions of people
are these unrecognizables and we can
never
quite be sure only they can be sure
in their relation with with the divine
but this holds out a possibility and you
might say
well that's only a possibility but
that's all that kierkegaard is
pretending that it
actually is for us and in order to
realize that possibility
one has to take the leap
into existence
and develop as he says as an essential
human being
you